We have a blank plus 261 is equal to 630
and I advise you to stop the video
and check if you can find out how empty it is.
There are several ways to solve this.
Let's picture it on a numerical axis.
This is my numerical axis here.
And we could start from the empty,
or I will mark it with a question mark.
We could start with the question mark
and if we add
261 to it,
plus plus 261,
we will get to 630.
We'll get to 630.
This is the number 630 here,
which means that if
we had started at 630,
and we had to subtract 261,
if we had to go in the other direction,
if we had to get 261. Let's do it.
So minus 261,
minus 261,
we would go back to the empty,
we would go back to our questionnaire.
There are many ways to calculate this,
but I will try to solve it in a way,
which I would actually use if I decide in my mind,
or who will simplify my calculations.
Just one of many ways
to find this.
The way I would think is, first of all I would have taken out 200,
I would first get 200.
This is roughly drawn, I do not exactly observe the scale.
So I would get 200,
this here is minus 200,
which I would reach 430.
This can be calculated in mind.
I just took 2 hundreds out of here.
Let's see now, I want to get 60.
So then I would get 60.
Minus 60.
Let's think, 430 minus 60.
That's 43 decades minus 6 tens.
That would be 37 dots or 370.
So we get to 370.
And finally we'll get another 1.
We have to pull out 200, 60 and then 1 (261).
So, 370 minus 1
is 369.
Therefore, this is 369,
369.
Another way we could figure this out
is to exchange the order.
We could say: "If blank plus 261 is 630,
then 261
plus empty is equal to 630 ".
All I did was change the order here,
but this is displayed differently
on the numerical axis.
Let me again make a numerical axis.
Here is my numerical axis.
And I could start from 261.
So this time I start from 261.
261.
And I want to get to 630.
And I want to get to 630,
and the number it adds will be equal to the blank.
Let's see how much I need to add to get 630.
And I'll add numbers that are easy to read.
I could add 9, I could add 9.
And why 9?
Because that's how I get to 270,
which is a sympathetic, round number.
And then I could add 30 here,
to get to 300. Let me do it.
Plus 30.
I do not respect the scale,
but that will take me to 300.
And then, from 300 to 630,
I would just add 330.
I would just add 330 here.
How much did I add?
That's 39 plus 330,
this is 369.
I added 369.
These are the ways to find the above value,
all the ways to solve the problem.